[Musique]
vous le rappelle il y a les gestes
barrière voilà c'est fait fameuse
chanson
de nos amis dans une vidéo publiée ce
matin sur les réseaux sociaux à
l'occasion de la rentrée scolaire
emmanuel macron a montré le portrait des
vidéastes mcfly et carlitos souvenez
vous au printemps dernier les 10
millions de vues atteint par la chanson
des youtuber sur les gestes barrières le
concours d'anecdotes à l'elysée et enfin
ce fameux gage du chef de l'état je sais
pas quoi vous dire personnellement
aujourd'hui il ya derrière une réalité
assez effectivement il ya des gens qui
meurent moins que la grippe mais qui qui
donne des dommages collatéraux plus
grave aussi pour les familles alors
qu'est ce que vous proposez comme
solution pour que la france va bien il
est un peu des fois une hystérie
médiatique contre ce que vous étiez
anti-vaccins que vous étiez alors
c'était le prétexte de par rapport à
l'or
être anti vhc faut déjà avoir un vaccin
est aujourd'hui la loi européenne ne
reconnaît pas cette thérapie da comme
metal max thérapie génique donc je suis
pas anti vaccins et je ne veux pas me
faire ce vaccin en fait les accents et
ceux ci
on te met à entonner un petit truc qui
fait que ton organisme va construire de
quoi se défendre contre le virus fait de
gens qui sont vaccinés et comprendre les
protections comme on fait la plus on
arrive vraiment à le bloquer à ce que tu
vois il se finalement il se perd un peu
dans la nature et qu'ils arrêtent de
nous embêter
mais il n'y a pas de risque zéro et je
me dirige dans le plateau voilà avec
tous ceux qui ne pouvaient pas engendrer
sur le bateau qui ne souhaitait pas
rentrer sur le bateau wascana qu'ils ne
souhaitaient pas rentrer sur le plateau
ce soir dont btp en direct il y aura
donc deux plateaux un plateau en
extérieur un plateau en intérieur vous
imaginez un petit peu ce que ça nous a
coûté j'ai pris position ci-contre le
passé à l'inter parce que pour moi ce ne
sont pas des mesures scientifiques
le métro sans passe le train passe ces
scientifiques ces politiques les
professeurs non vacciner les élèves
vaccinés ces scientifiques ces
politiques l'assemblée nationale s'en
passent et les concerts avec passe ces
scientifiques non ces politiques vous
souvenez de cette expression peut être
monsieur max à propos du sida lorsque
nous avions pensé trouver un traitement
et que à la fin on s'est planté il ya
l'expression cas de murray qui a
traversé les siècles c'est ce qui se
passe quand le politique mais sac à main
dans la culotte du scientifique et bien
c'est ce qui se passe de nouveau je peux
vous donner par contre le nom des
chakras et je vais le faire de tête mais
quand je lis de tête faut que je baisse
la tête il ya la moule adhara la sva dit
stan a la manie pour à la natte à la vie
chaude à l'âge n'a hélas à charron dire
à des danses de l'été
[Applaudissements]
il manque la strass donné 15 heures
notre pays a été un phare dans le monde
et c'est le frère est éteint le pays des
lumières c'est le pays des lumières et
c'est sévère ce que vous dites là assez
très sévère mais comment vous appelez
comment vous appelez un endroit où les
les droits de l'homme les droits du
travail les règles européennes sont
bafoués comment vous appelez ça vous
dire que la france est une dictature
même sanitaires et quelque chose
d'obscène d'abord parce que les gens qui
prononce ce genre de phrases n'ont
jamais mis les pieds en afghanistan en
corée du nord ou en chine
la ville de corrèze qui a alors autant
les questions qui toquent youtube et les
demandes et dédicaces appelé au
président questions sur kaboul un peu
moins très mauvaise idée regardez comme
le président va calmer les experts en
géopolitique en deux secondes c'est ce
qui se passe à kaboul
pourquoi tu me demande ça alors je suis
comme michel sardou j'ai fait les deux
écoles et que c'était tout oublier la
nuit des carmagnole eiffel deux écoles
et j'ai dû oublier la nuit des
carmagnole
malaurie j'ai beaucoup aimé la france je
suis arrivé j'ai vu beaucoup d'arbres et
bien voilà à l'abri
la seule chose qui manque ce sont les
gars mais si je pouvais je viendrai bien
la
seule chose qui manque
fimalac
vient à l'épisode du allez viens
non bien maman non
mais les envier ce n'est que les femmes
sérieusement oui c'est vrai ça que nous
soyons des contrats pas le chéquier
jeunes s'est tout de suite un peu voilà
un petit côté george clooney qu'on
attend ça c'est un truc on a
aussi des femmes
c'est toute l'équipe de foot irlandaise
masculine qui a fait un beau geste vous
allez le voir partir de maintenant de
septembre ils acceptent de baisser leur
paie lors des rencontres internationales
pour que l'équipe féminine puisse gagner
la même chose que sympa alors comment on
s'assoit avec une jupe aussi court
comme ça
c'est pas les premiers quand même il ya
eu l'angleterre le brésil l'australie la
norvège la nouvelle-zélande qui eux
aussi publiquement se sont engagés à
l'égalité salariale entre les deux
équipes donc je sais pas moi ça pourrait
peut-être inspiré les français qui sait
bonne chance qu'il fait du partage fait
200 pompe par jour ma chère et je suis
un dieu du ping pong bon et sinon si ça
vous intéresse j'ai commencé à sombrer à
20,50 euros et c'est le seul mec que je
connais qui fait 200 pont par jour et
c'est vrai j'ai assisté à ça c'est une
mais qui tient mais kia chez qui ça ne
se voit pas c'était latent des caméras
s'il vous plaît caméra le profil c'est
important caméras caméras un profil
hockey va falloir trouver une autre
excuse 1 messieurs pour les petites des
petites poignées d'amour il n'y a pas de
chute du métabolisme donc si vous prenez
du poids pendant cette période alors
sauf cas exceptionnel bien évidemment
mais si vous prenez du poids c'est que
vous êtes trop sédentaire ou que vous
avez des repas trop riches
un petit sachet
dissoudre dans les toilettes oui qui est
censé agir sur l'ensemble des
désagréments rencontrés en ces lieux
alors oui les désagréments odeurs
projection éclaboussures salissures et
le bruit le célèbre plouf
mais câline donc sept airbags des wc
forme une sorte de mousse blanche et
épaisse dans la cuvette et d'après ses
inventaires elle permet d'éviter les
blocages psychologiques mes toilettes
qui sont quand même comme ça moi j'ai
des fesses comme ça donc comment se
faire frapper pays et je vous parle pas
d'eux des zones besoin en plus de ne pas
avoir de style dans tout les cas je ne
trouve pas catania mais les gens passent
pas c'est vraiment un moment de détente
dessert route et ses deux copines
s'éclate dans la gadoue
c'est qui déjà
c'est un prénom cruz 5 ans bruno oger
bouteilles réutilisables ou fille un peu
cruche gourdes oui